hi schön dass ihr dabei seid bei ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr eingeschaltet
habt ja vor ein paar Stunden kamen die
Meldung wahrscheinlich auch per Push
Nachricht auf euer Telefon der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof in Den
Haag er lässt einen Haftbefehl gegen
Wladimir Putin wegen mutmaßlichen
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine das
Gericht wirft ihm vor für die
Verschleppung ukrainischer Kinder nach
Russland verantwortlich zu sein lasst
uns direkt mal reinhören wie das heute
von piota hofmannski das ist der
Präsident des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof das begründet hat
today heute am 17 März 2023 hatte
Internationale Strafgerichtshof im
Zusammenhang mit der Ukraine zwei
Haftbefehle gegen Wladimir Putin den
Präsidenten der Russischen Föderation
und gegen Maria Lover Bella war die
Beauftragte des russischen Präsidenten
für Kinderrechte wegen des mutmaßlichen
Kriegsverbrechens der Deportation von
Kindern aus den Ukrainisch besetzten
Gebieten in die Russische Föderation
erlassen nach internationalem Recht ist
das Besatzungsmächten untersagt
Zivilisten aus dem Gebiet indem sie
leben in andere Gebiete zu verlegen
Kinder genießen nach der Genfer
Konvention besonderen Schutz
ja zwei Haftbefehle also einmal gegen
den russischen Präsidenten Putin und
seine
kinderrechtsbeauftragte Maria lewowa
billo war für die mutmaßliche
Deportation von ukrainischen Kindern
nach Russland da sind jetzt viele Fragen
offen was genau wird Putin vorgeworfen
was ist das eigentlich für ein
Kriegsverbrechen aber natürlich auch was
bringt denn jetzt so ein Haftbefehl
gegen Putin darüber wollen wir heute
hier sprechen und zwar zum einen mit
Professor Dr Stefanie Box sie ist
Expertin für internationale Strafrecht
an der Universität Marburg und mit dem
freien Journalisten Arndt Ginzel der war
selbst in Person und hat dort zu
verschleppen Kindern recherchiert und
einen Film gemacht und wie immer hier
möchte ich darüber nicht nur mit denen
sprechen sondern auch mit euch da
draußen habt ihr Fragen zum Thema habt
ihr Anregungen oder Meinungen schreibt
sie uns gerne hier in den Youtube Chat
oder per Mail an ZDF heute - live at
zdf.de jetzt begrüße ich aber erstmal
Professor Stefanie Bock hier bei mir im
Studio hat sich bekommen
guten Abend
Frau Bock was haben Sie denn heute als
erstes gedacht als sie diese Push
Benachrichtigung aufs Handy bekommen
haben waren sie überrascht
ich war erfreut denn das ist trotz allem
ein großes Symbol dass die
Strafverfolgung ernst genommen wird und
sich ernst nehmen ernst genommen werden
will und es hier mit aller Konsequenz
gegen die Verbrechen in der Ukraine
vorgegangen werden soll und zwar
unabhängig vom Status des Beschuldigten
jetzt klingt ja so ein Haftbefehl
erstmal groß das klingt groß und wichtig
welche Auswirkungen hat denn so ein
Haftbefehl jetzt aber ganz konkret
verändert sich dadurch irgendwas was
sind jetzt so die nächsten Schritte
das nächste wäre jetzt natürlich
optimalerweise die Festnahme der
Beschuldigten also von Putin und seiner
kinderrechtsbeauftragten das wird aber
erstmal praktisch daran gescheitern dass
sich das niemand ihn tatsächlich
festnehmen kann wo es dann selber
erkennt den Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof nicht an das heißt
keine russische Behörde wird Putin
festnehmen die Mitgliedstaaten des
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof die
grundsätzlich verpflichtet sind den
Haftbefehl zu vollstrecken also die
Person festzunehmen die haben keinerlei
Befugnisse in Russland das heißt eine
Festnahme kommt eigentlich nur dann in
Betracht wenn Putin das Land verlässt
was aber bereits jetzt spürbar ist ist
dann natürlich dass der internationale
Haftbefehl zu einer Beschränkung von
Putins Reisefreiheit führt also er kann
als
amtierender staatschaft eines großen
Landes nicht mehr unbehändigt durch die
Welt reisen er muss in dem Augenblick wo
er ein
Mitgliedstaat das internationalen
Strafgericht damit rechnen festgenommen
zu werden
wir haben ja schon direkt eine Frage aus
der Community zum Thema und zwar fragt
Vektor warum kommt dieser Haftbefehl
jetzt erst ein Jahr nach dem
Kriegsbeginn
weil natürlich Beweise gesammelt
gesichtet und bewertet werden müssen das
Verbrechen was vergleichsweise eindeutig
erscheint nämlich das Verbrechen des
Angriffskrieges also der Vorwurf
überhaupt den Krieg gestartet zu haben
für den ist der internationale
strafgerichtszug nicht zuständig in der
kann nicht in den haarverfolgt werden
das heißt der Ankläger musste Beweise
dafür finden das Putin selbst für
Kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich ist das
bedeutet es muss halt nicht nur
nachgewiesen werden das im Ukraine Krieg
Kriegsverbrechen begangen worden sondern
auch das Putin selbst dafür
verantwortlich ist und dieser Nachweis
die Nachweis zu führen wird umso
schwerer je größer dieses Tanz zwischen
den Verbrechen in der Ukraine und der
Person hier Putin im Kreml in Moskau die
größte diese Distanz ist und dafür
braucht man Zeit um diese Beweise
zusammenzustellen
diese Deportation von Kindern nach
Russland das ist ja nicht das einzige
mutmaßliche Kriegsverbrechen was Putin
vorgeworfen wird wir erinnern uns zum
Beispiel an diese Gräueltaten in Butcher
vor einigen Monaten was glauben Sie denn
warum bezieht man sich jetzt in diesem
Statement heute so konkret auf diese
Deportation der Kinder
natürlich etwas vermessen jetzt zu
spekulieren was die Entscheidung des
Anklägers beeinflusst haben mögen sich
auf diese Verbrechen zum konzentrieren
aber spricht viel dafür dass das
Verbrechen sind die vergleichsweise gut
nachweisbar sind sofern es um
Gräueltaten in beispielsweise wie ein
Butcher geht es ist halt umso schwerer
nachzuweisen dass Putin selbst in die
Begehung dieser Taten involviert hat
dass er sie individuell angewiesen hat
oder dass er von Moskau aus die
Möglichkeit hatte diese Verbrechen zu
verhindern was voraussetzt dass er eine
effektive Kontrolle gehabt hat über das
Geschehen in Wutscher das ist sehr
schwer zu beweisen die Verbrechen die
der Ankläger jetzt in den Fokus gerückt
hat sind taten die eng verknüpft sind
mit der Gesamtstrategie Russlands die
deswegen deutlich leichter zur
russischen Führung
zurückverfolgt werden können und dann
ist hier deutlich einfacher sein die
individuelle Verantwortlichkeit gut
hinzulegen als wir Verbrechen
womöglicherweise von Seiten der
Verteidigung angeführt werden kann dass
es sich um Einzeltaten von Soldaten
handelt die aber in keinen weiteren
Zusammenhang und kein Kontext mit der
Stadtspitze stehen
wir haben hier noch mal eine Frage
speziell zu der eventuellen Ausführung
dieses Haftbefehls und zwar fragt
Dietmar Scheibe wer kann den Putin im
Falle einer Reise ins Ausland festnehmen
und daran anschließend fragt Eduard
Kunst würde Putin also verhaftet sollte
er zum Beispiel an einer un-versammlung
in New York teilnehmen
New York ist schon mal ein schwieriger
Fall weil das liegt daran dass der dass
die USA kein Mitgliedschaft das
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof sind
die sind also nicht direkt verpflichtet
diesen Haftbefehl auszuführen das wäre
interessant wie sich die USA in dieser
Situation verhalten würden
generell gilt das Staatsoberhäupter wie
Putin eine sogenannte absolute Immunität
genießen das heißt Sie können
grundsätzlich nicht festgenommen werden
an der Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
hat aber schon mal in einem anderen
Verfahren klargestellt dass es nicht
gilt wenn ein internationaler Haftbefehl
vorliegt also der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof kann
diese absolute Immunität aufheben und
das bedeutet das Putin
festgenommen werden muss von den
Mitgliedstaaten des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof also wenn er sich
beispielsweise
in ein Land der EU das sind alles
Mitgliedstaaten das internationalen
strafberichts
du hast es gerade schon sie haben es
gerade schon angedeutet das sind jetzt
sehr theoretische Fragen gerade hier
fragt trotzdem jemand und zwar Paul
klinzing welche Strafe würde den Putin
theoretisch drohen falls er wirklich
verhaftet wurde
das müssten dann die ähm Beweise im
Einzelfall ergeben
das werden typischerweise spricht der
internationale Gericht so sehr hohe
Freiheitsstrafe aus
und wir haben noch eine Frage von Sven
Odendahl auf Facebook wie sehr wird das
mögliche Friedenslösung mit Putin oder
andere Lösungen jenseits von Putin
erleichtern oder erschweren
das ist immer die generelle Frage in
welchen Verhältnis steht
Völkerstrafrecht zufriedenschaffung man
kann immer überlegen ob es gut ist
Ermittlungen einzuleiten gerade wenn sie
sich gegen Personen richten die man
möglicherweise noch für
Friedensverhandlungen brauchen kann
generell würde ich sagen ein
langfristigen Frieden ein dauerhaften
Frieden kann man nicht ohne
Gerechtigkeit schaffen das heißt
irgendwann braucht man Mechanismen um
begannes Unrecht aufzuarbeiten und dann
bis jetzt keine große Bereitschaft sehen
konnten dass die russische Seite diesen
Konflikt durch Verhandlung lösen möchte
glaube ich dass sie keine negativen
Auswirkungen auf Friedensprozesse zu
erwarten sind wahrscheinlich auch keine
positiven also die russische Seite wird
sich natürlich jetzt wahrscheinlich eher
noch mehr
abschotten und ist als weiteren andere
von Seiten des Westen sehen aber ich
glaube nicht dass damit eine effektive
Verschlechterung der aktuellen Situation
einhergeht
Frau Bock danke erstmal für ihre
Antworten bis hierhin wir sprechen uns
gleich noch mal
ich würde aber gerne mit euch jetzt noch
mal einen Blick werfen auf den Grund für
diesen Haftbefehl heute und das ist ja
wir haben es jetzt schon mehrmals gehört
die Verschleppung ukrainischer Kinder
nach Russland und das fällt wie wir
gerade gehört haben eben unter diese
Kategorie Kriegsverbrechen und da gibt
es einen der war vor Ort der hat dort
mit Eltern gesprochen der hat diese
Taten tatsächlich nachverfolgt und das
ist an Ginzel er ist freier Journalist
und hat gemeinsam mit Armin Körper einen
Film über genau diese Taten für ZDF Zoom
gemacht lasst uns da mal reingucken
so sieht es aus wenn die Besatzer auf
kinderjagd gehen Person im Sommer 2022
noch ist die Region unter russischer
Kontrolle die Kinder hier sind weisen
sie sollen nach Russland verschleppt
werden auch Natalia war mit ihren 15
weisen Kindern in diesem Haus drei
Monate lang
zuvor hatten die Russen sie bereits das
einem anderen Heim nachher schon
gebracht doch eines Morgens kommt auch
hier ein Bus der Besatzer die sagten
wenn du nicht in 10 Minuten gepackt hast
gehen die Kinder ohne dich wir nehmen
sie dir weg ich hatte keine Wahl
es war beängstigend wir wussten nicht
wohin sie uns bringen dann sagten sie
sie würden uns in die Ferien bringen
die Reise führt zum Fluss Nepper von
dort geht es auf die Halbinsel Krim
Natalia wird klar sie bringen Sie nach
Russland bei Nacht mit dem Zug über die
Brücke von Kerk die krimbrücke
vollläufiges ziel dieses Haus in der
russischen Stadt anapa am Schwarzen Meer
[Musik]
in dem Gebäude waren etwa 500 Menschen
auf vier Stockwerken es waren sehr viele
Kinder da sie stammten alle aus der
oblastrealson sie kamen alle aus der
Ukraine
ich denke sie bringen sie dorthin damit
sie sich daran gewöhnen damit sie
bleiben
die größte Gefahr ist dass die Kinder
sich womöglich anpassen aber sie hängen
an mir im Herzen die Ukraine es sind ja
ukrainische Kinder
doch sie sollen Russen werden so zeigen
es diese russischen Propaganda Bilder
von bis zu 14.000 verschleppten Kindern
spricht die ukrainische Regierung sie
werden ihrer Identität beraubt und
russifiziert die Staatsbürgerschaft auf
dem Kinderrechte
ich stehe hier und begreife dass diese
Kinder sich komplett verändert haben es
ist fantastisch
Natalia und ihren Kindern gelingt die
Flucht mit von ihr selbst gefälschten
Dokumenten heute sind sie in Georgien
ja ich habe die Dokumente gefälscht aber
ich habe es für die Kinder getan und es
hat funktioniert was aber wenn nicht sie
hätten in Russland bleiben müssen
[Musik]
die Verschleppung Russifizierung und
Umerziehung von Menschen Tradition aus
verwirrzeiten eine Praxis die Putins
Russland heute noch anwendet auch an
wehrlosen Kindern
ja das sind ganz drückende Bilder die
wir da sehen umso wichtiger dass wir
darüber sprechen hallo schön dass du bei
uns bist
da sind Bilder die hast du aufgenommen
du warst selber in herson und hast dir
ein Bild der Lage gemacht mit was für
Eindrücken bist du zurückgekommen was
hast du dort erlebt wen hast du
kennengelernt
ja ich habe Gelegenheit gehabt mit sehr
vielen Eltern zu sprechen mit Leitern
von Heim zu sprechen die Kinder
versteckt haben vor den russischen
Besatzern
die die Kinder versteckt haben damit die
Kinder eben nicht nach Russland gebracht
werden ich habe Eltern gesprochen die
ihre Kinder in sogenannte erholungslager
geschickt haben und nach der nach dem
Abzug der russischen Armee aus
Herrschern eben diese Kinder nicht mehr
zurückgekommen haben und da ist viel
Verunsicherung der ist viel Angst um die
Kinder dass man die Kinder nie wieder
sieht
und ähm ja viel Ratlosigkeit aus auch
wie man jetzt mit der Situation umgeht
soll man nach Russland fahren die Kinder
zurückholen
ja und dann war die Frau die
Heimleiterin die wir gerade auch im Film
gesehen haben
die quasi unter Druck und mit Androhung
von Gewalt eben nach Russland mit ihnen
15 Heimkindern gebracht wurde und der
ist gelungen ist aus Russland zu fliehen
indem Sie Dokumente gefälscht hat und
das war schon also es hat schon
nachgehalten auch dieses Interview mit
mit ihr weil es mir auch klar gemacht
hat warum das unter Strafe steht Kinder
zu deportieren wegzubringen
kannst du dir erklären was für eine
Strategie oder was für ein strategischen
Nutzen es in so einem Krieg hat
insbesondere Kinder zu verschleppen wem
dient das wozu macht man das
also es gibt unterschiedliche
Ansichten also
ein eine mögliche eine mögliche Grund
kann sein dass man damit die
Moral der Ukraine beeinträchtigen will
indem man sozusagen verunsichert die
stabilisiert Angst verbreitet
eine andere mögliche Erklärung ist dass
das ganze auch nach innen gerichtet ist
nach Russland die man sich mit Kindern
mit ukrainischen Kindern zeigt die ähm
ja der Propaganda vorführt und dadurch
eben nach innen wirkt und sagt wir sind
die guten wir machen etwas Richtiges
das kann der zweite Weg sein der dritte
wäre durchaus da lassen sich auch
durchaus russifizierungs Tendenzen
ablesen die wir auch in Schulen
beispielsweise gefunden haben wir waren
ja in herson aber auch in anderen
besetzten Gebieten jemals besetzten
Gebieten in Schulen gewesen wo gesehen
haben wie das aussehen soll wie die
Kinder künftig erzogen werden sollten
und der russischen Besatzungsmacht und
das bedeutete dass man vor allem die
russische Geschichte lernt dass man die
Ukraine hassen lernt auch das waren
Element
und entfremdet von ihrer Heimat
eine Frage aus der Community an Dich von
Ayla 888 die fragt wie viele Kinder
wurden denn verschleppt hast du
irgendeine Richtzahl die an die
Dimension so ein bisschen klarer macht
ja eine absolute Zahl zu nennen ist halt
sehr kompliziert man kann sich immer auf
die Zahlen der Ukraine Stützen es gibt
Zahlen auch letzten Endes das sind aber
auch Schätzungen von von den Vereinten
Nationen
die Ukraine sagt 15.000
es könnten inzwischen auch schon wieder
mehr sein weil es immer davon also
dieses Phänomen tritt vor allen Dingen
in dem Gebieten auf oder das Verbrechen
tritt dort auf wo ukrainische
Besatzungsbehörden
Besatzungsmächte waren und man sieht es
erst wenn die abgezogen sind und es sind
ja noch weite Teile des Landes unter
ja beide Teile noch besetzt und wie viel
Kinder letzten Endes dort verschwunden
sind verschwinden werden das wird
wahrscheinlich erst sehen wenn die
russischen Streitkräfte abgezogen sind
du hast in deinem Film der übrigens sehr
empfehlenswert ist ja auch über die
kinderrechtsbeauftragte Maria levo war
billowa berichtet die heute auch diesen
Haftbefehl ausgesetzt wurde wer ist
diese Frau kannst du uns zu der noch mal
was erzählen
ja sie tritt nach außen hin sehr modern
auf jungen
ihr Mann soweit ich das verstanden habe
war früher glaube ich ein IT-Spezialist
der dann in die russische orthodoxe
Kirche eingetreten ist sie hat eine
ganze Reihe von Kindern adoptiert soll
auch ein Kind aus Mario Pool adoptiert
haben und sie ist quasi omnipräsent rund
um das Thema ukrainische Kinder sie
lässt sich Filmen auf dem Weg mit
Kindern aus der Ukraine nach Russland es
gibt Bilder das russischen Fernsehens
wie sie Kinder an Pflegeeltern übergibt
sie lässt sich in ja in in Einrichtung
Kindereinrichtungen abpflichten mit
Kindern es gab ja dann diesen anderen
Fall den wir da noch mit ähm
recherchiert haben das Kinder teilweise
aus der Ukraine auch in einem SOS
Kinderdorf gelandet sind auch da gibt es
Bilder
also sie ist omnipräsent und ich würde
sagen dass sie auf sie geht auch diese
Gesetzesinitiative zurück dass letztlich
Putin den Weg frei gemacht hatten ich
sage jetzt mal eine Möglichkeit zu
schaffen dass diese ukrainischen Kinder
in russischen Pass bekommen und
adoptiert werden können also all das hat
sie vorbereitet all das hat sie
unterstützt und sie ist in der ganzen
Thematik eben um die präsent sichtbar
wir haben hier noch mal eine Frage aus
der Community für dich die sich auch auf
den Film bzw den Ausschnitt bezieht den
wir gesehen haben da ging es ja unter
anderem um eine Frau die mit weißen
Kindern es geschafft hat aus diese aus
Russland zu entkommen mit gefälschten
Dokumenten und hier fragt MC 1 2 1 3 6
sind das ausschließlich weisen Kinder
oder werden Kinder auch wirklich Ihren
Eltern weggenommen
in dem Fall sind das Kinder die wirklich
ihren Eltern und Angehörigen weggenommen
werden
insofern trifft wahrscheinlich dort der
Begriff Internat eher zu das sind das
war etwas größeres eine größere
Einrichtung etwa 60 km von herson
entfernt und diese ganze Gruppe und das
wird dort erzählt auch in der ganzen
Geschichte die wird erst aus dem ein Ort
nachher Sound verlegt
gegen den Willen der Kinder aber auch
der der Leiterin und von Herr von geht
es dann schließlich mit dem Abzug der
russischen Streitkräfte Richtung
Russland und sie hat immer wieder
erklärt dass sie sich dagegen gewehrt
hat und dass man die angedroht hat dass
man dann ihr die Kinder wegnimmt und
genauso erklärt sie es ja auch also
sie hätte also sie ist natürlich über
glücklich dass sie es geschafft hat aus
Russland rauszukommen schon alleine im
Bewusstsein dessen dass die Kinder
selber noch Eltern haben oder Verwandte
haben die auf die Kinder warten
ja das ist ja jetzt quasi ein noch
halbwegs schönes Beispiel hier fragt
auch jemand fair von Herrn ist wie groß
sind denn die Chancen dass die Kinder
zurück zu ihren Familien geführt werden
können sind denn alle Kinder dort mit
einer Art Leiterin unterwegs ja
wahrscheinlich nicht oder
nee das ganz unterschiedliche in der
ersten Phase
hat man vor allen Dingen Kinder aus Heim
aus der aus den sogenannten Separatisten
Gebieten geholt und nach Russland
gebracht
dort liegen die die schwierig
schonkeiten wesentlich größer also weil
teilweise leben die Eltern nicht mehr
teilweise leben die Eltern auf
Ukrainisch kontrollierten Gebiet die
Kinder sind teilweise in Russland in
ganz oben in Richtung Norden gebracht
worden oder ganz zweitausend Kilometer
entfernt Richtung Osten gebracht worden
es ist auch nicht so richtig klar wie
viele sind dass die Frage kam ja vorhin
wirklich sind wie viele Kinder sind
letztlich doch gelandet man kann es halt
nur anhand der Bildern etwa abschätzen
das ist Massen sein müssen die nach
Russland transportiert und und ja das
ist eine gute Frage wie groß die Chance
dort ist dass sie zurückkommen Kinder
wiederum die in diesen erholungslagern
Waren die nach der russischen Armee
nicht mehr zurückkommen konnten dort
glaube ich sind die Chancen besser weil
ich habe gehört und ich habe auch mit
Eltern gesprochen den es auch gelungen
ist Kinder zurückzuholen
das lief dann über Vermittlung über das
Internationale Rote Kreuz aber es ist
schwierig es ist ein es ist ein ganz
schwieriger Fall hängt oftmals davon ab
ob die russischen Autoritäten das
zulassen oder auch nicht aber es ist
nicht komplett aussichtslos
du hast es ja gerade schon erwähnt die
Eltern mit denen du gesprochen hast
deren größter Wunsch ist es natürlich
ihre Kinder wiederzusehen glaubst du
trotzdem dass du eine Meldung wie heute
also so ein Haftbefehl gegen Putin für
dieses Verbrechen das denen das irgendwo
Hoffnung gibt
ja sicher wird das Hoffnung geben aber
im Vordergrund steht dort im Augenblick
wirklich dass die Kinder zurückkommen
das ist glaube ich
es ist ja auch eine unglaubliche
Unsicherheit da es gibt Familien die
getrauen sich aus Herz also herzern wird
stark umkämpft das muss man jetzt dazu
sagen ne wird stark umkämpft es gibt
Familien die gehen dort nicht weg weil
sie schlichten ergreifend Angst haben
dass ihre Kinder nicht mehr zurückkehren
oder sie den Draht oder den Kontext oder
alles verlieren und eigentlich müssten
die Familien raus aus der Stadt
aber ich denke bei denen Kindern bei den
Familien wo es gelungen ist sie wieder
zusammenzuführen glaube ich ist es ein
Zeichen es ist ein Zeichen in die
Zukunft das irgendwann diese Verbrechen
verfolgt werden und das ist vielleicht
irgendwann mal zu einem zu einer Anklage
kommt es ist ein ja starkes Zeichen
ja danke an bis hierhin dass du meine
Fragen und die Fragen der Community
beantwortet hast und noch mal eine große
Empfehlung für den Film den Abend
gemacht hat für ZDF suchen danke schön
danke
und wir schalten jetzt noch mal direkt
rüber weil ihr eine ganze Menge Fragen
gestellt habt zu diesem Prozess der
Haftbefehle und was das eigentlich alles
genau bedeutet was das möglich macht was
vielleicht auch nicht Frau Bock hier
sehen wir uns wieder ich habe gleich
direkt eine Frage von Theater der
gefragt hat wie hat denn eigentlich die
russische Seite auf diesen Haftbefehl
heute reagiert
mit der Aussage das ist halt praktisch
nichts ändert ähm russland hat ja den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
zu keiner Zeit anerkannt und Sie dies
natürlich erneut als Angriff primär das
Westens was auch Erkenntnis der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof
natürlich nicht nur ein gerichtetes
Westen ist sondern von viel mehr starken
getragen wird
wir haben ja auch noch mal eine Frage zu
so einem ja rechtlichen Prozess noch mal
von einer 888 dieser was Bedarf ist denn
eigentlich an Beweisen und Putin selbst
zu belasten Beispiele werden super
also Beispiele die man jetzt zum
Beispiel bei diesem bei diesem
verbrechnungen wie es geht bringen kann
wir haben ja eben gehört wie stark diese
Überführung von Kindern Teil der Politik
ist das heißt hier kann man aus beweisen
Beweise tatsächlich schon die gesamte
russische Politik der Erlass von
Gesetzen zur
schnellen Eingliederung ukrainischer
Kinder nehmen da steht ja eine
politische Strategie dahinter das heißt
das ist schon mal ein basisstein für
Beweise dann lässt sich auf jeden Fall
natürlich Zeugenaussagen Interviews mit
den
Kindern die zurück zu ihren Familien
gekommen sind mit den Eltern und mit
sozusagen überhaupt erst mal diese
Deportation nachzuweisen
da sind die Zeugenaussagen natürlich von
entscheidender Bedeutung und dann alles
was man an Kommunikation nachweisen kann
also man muss die Befehlsketten
nachvollziehen wie sind diese Truppen da
vor Ort gekommen und haben diese Kinder
abgeholt wer hat diese Anordnung erteilt
aufgrund von welcher Politik und diese
Befehlskette vollzieht man dann Schritt
für Schritt bis man dann hoffentlich
irgendwann an der Stadtspitze gelandet
ist
und Userin Lee fragt wird es nur bei
diesem einen Haftbefehl bleiben oder
könnten in Zukunft weitere
Gerichtsurteile oder ähnliches fallen
wie ist denn quasi der Prozess bei sowas
bleibt es jetzt dabei oder ist da noch
mehr zu erwarten
also dann
zu erwarten ist auf jeden Fall mehr also
sicherlich ist das nicht der einzige
Haftbefehl vom Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof den wir in der
Situation Ukraine sehen werden
es wird es besteht auch die Möglichkeit
dass der Vorwurf gegen Putin noch mal
erweitert wird also der Ankläger wird ja
weiter ermitteln weitere Hinweise auf
Kriegsverbrechen und die dafür
verantwortlichen sammeln und sollte sich
da der Verdacht herausstellen das Putin
möglicherweise auch für Verbrechen die
die Massaker persönlich verantwortlich
ist wird ein neuer Haftbefehl oder ein
erweiterte Haftbefehl beantragt werden
zudem sehen wir auch ganz viele
Strafverfolgungsmaßnahmen in den
Nationalstaaten das heißt wir haben ja
nicht nur Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof sondern auch die
Niederlande Frankreich Deutschland
alle Staaten die selber wegen
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine
ermitteln da haben wir auch Verfahren
sehen in diesen Staaten nicht gegen
Putin
Putin selber kann als Staatschef nur von
dem internationalen stoffgerichtshof
verlangt werden aber halt ergänzende
Verfahren die dann vielleicht in der
Gesamtheit zu einer Aufarbeitung der in
der Ukraine begangenen Verbrechen führen
werden
und hier fragt noch mal jemand
zum Thema eventuelle Festnahme jetzt
vielleicht sehr sehr weit in die Zukunft
gesprochen oder sehr theoretisch ist es
eigentlich eine Kriegserklärung an einen
Staat dessen Präsidenten zu verhaften
also im Normalfall ist das eine
Kriegserklärung ist es sicherlich nicht
im eigentlichen Sinne eine
Kriegserklärung sitzt immer die
Anwendung von Gewalt gegen die
territoriale Integrität eines anderen
Staates voraus das wäre das was wir im
engeren Sinne einfach gesagt unter einem
Krieg verstehen normalerweise ist aber
natürlich die Festnahme eines Fremden
Staatsoberhaupt ein völkerrechtswidriger
Akt das verletzt die absolute Immunität
der
Staatsoberhaupt und damit das Recht der
Staaten der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof hat sich aber schon
immer auf den Standpunkt gestellt das
geht eben nicht
wenn es ein internationalen Haftbefehl
von Internationalen Strafgerichtshof ist
dahinter steckt die Idee ähm das ist
keine Straffreiheit für diese schwersten
Verbrechen gehen kann das Völkermord
Verbrechen die Menschlichkeit und
Kriegsverbrechen so schwerwiegend sind
das ist doch keine Ausnahme von der
Strafverfolgung geben kann ist das
Völker Strafrecht durchgesetzt worden
werden muss und zwar unabhängig vom
Ansehen oder der politischen Stellung
einer Person
und wir haben hier noch eine Frage für
Sie das Interesse aus der Community zu
diesem Thema ist wirklich groß inwieweit
hat denn der Haftbefehl Auswirkungen auf
die politischen Unterstützer Putins
könnte der Haftbefehl international als
Warnung verstanden werden Putin zu
unterstützen wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt
mal in Richtung China gucken
dann gehört China auch zu den starken
internationalen Strafgerichtshof nicht
anerkennen deswegen sage ich zu
bezweifeln das ist große Auswirkungen
auf China haben wird das wird im Zweifel
wieder einen Frage sein wie man diesen
Haftbefehl
interpretiert
Unterstützer Putins werden
wahrscheinlich sagen dass das eine
weitere
Angriff ist da gibt es das Schlagwort
der läuft fair also der Kriegsführung
mit den Mitteln des Rechts ist ja der
internationale Strafgericht zu
möglicherweise von der Ukraine mit
instrumentalisiert wird um halt gegen
Putin vorzugehen
auf der anderen Seite ist es halt von
den Gegnern Proteins ein
unterstützungssignal dass sie jetzt auch
mit rechtlichen Mitteln versucht wird
den Ukraine Konflikt aufzuarbeiten also
es ist ein starkes politisches Statement
ich glaube nicht dass es man sich davon
allzu viel erhoffen darf dass es allzu
viel ändern den Blick auf die Staaten
die Putin unterstützen ich wage zu
bezweifeln dass die sich davon
nachhaltig beeindrucken lassen werden
und wir können zum Schluss noch mal
einen Blick in die Geschichte geben hier
fragt nämlich Harald da Haftbefehl gegen
Staatsoberhaupt hat es in der
Vergangenheit mal etwas Vergleichbares
gegeben
ja wir kennen Beispiele wir hatten den
specialcourt for Sierra Leone der gegen
Charles Taylor vorgegangen ist und den
auch verurteilt hat
als amtieren starb als Oberhaupt und vom
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof hatten
wir den ähm
Haftbefehl gegen engagier den der
erlassen wurde als engagiert noch
Präsident
war aber versteckt worden
aber immerhin erlassen worden wir kennen
also
durchaus einige Beispiele dafür aber es
ist trotzdem immer etwas Revolutionäres
wenn das Völker Strafrecht unter Beweis
stellt es ist eben nicht erlaubt dass
ich eine Person hinter seiner
politischen Stellung hinter seinem
politischen Hand verstecken kann sondern
dass das Recht wirklich unabhängig von
durchgesetzt werden sollen
lassen Sie uns jetzt ganz zum Schluss
noch mal darauf gucken dass haben sie
eben schon angedeutet welche symbolische
Kraft hatte in dieser Tag oder dieses
Urteil jetzt für die Ukraine
für die Ukraine ist das sicherlich ein
ganz großes Zeichen der Unterstützung
dass hier wirklich mit allen Mitteln
gegen
Kriegsverbrechen von russischer Seite
begangen werden vorgegangen wird und
zwar halt auch bis an höchster Stelle
gleichzeitig dieses Verbrechen der
Verschleppung von Kindern etwas was als
eines der zentralen
unrechtsbestände dieses Krieges von der
ukrainischen Seite wahrgenommen wird der
ukrainische general
Generalanwalt nimmt dies immer als
Beispiel um zu sagen es sei sogar
Völkermord was dort begangen wird weil
letztendlich die russische Seite die
Kinder der Ukraine nimmt russifiziert
und damit sozusagen das als Strategie
benutzen würde die ukrainische Nation zu
vernichten und damit ist das sicherlich
auch
ein großer Akt der Solidarität des
dieses Verbrechen das
die Ukraine von so zentraler Bedeutung
ist jetzt im Fokus des Internationale
Strafgerichtshof steht
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns waren ich
glaube ich spreche für mich und alle
anderen Zuschauer dass uns sicher dieser
Begriff Haftbefehl jetzt so ein bisschen
klarer geworden ist vielen Dank sehr
gerne
ich wäre zum Schluss noch mal einen
Blick in eure Kommentare und gucken an
was Ihr dazu zu sagen habt hier sagt
valor der Haftbefehl bringt überhaupt
nicht auf Facebook sagt aber Steffi
natürlich hat das erstmal keine
Konsequenzen aber es ist eine
internationale Aussage und das ist
wichtig ja
wie es weitergeht in der Ukraine wie es
weitergeht mit Wladimir Putin wir
bleiben auf jeden Fall weiter für euch
dran ich bedanke mich für eure
Kommentare und ich freue mich wenn ihr
wieder einschaltet das nächste Mal